Coleman endlessly our car tester
Michelle Assenmacher says that SUVs are
the most popular segment of the car
market right now and combining an SUV
with a hybrid engine is particularly hip
one example is the lexus NX 300h but the
exterior is something special the look
of this lexus is characterized by
striking lines and largely boxy shape
the front of the lexus NX 300h features
the diabolo grill typical of this make
at more than 4.5 meters long and with a
wheelbase of over 2.5 meters the car is
very spacious that's particularly
evident with the trunk it has a capacity
of 555 litres
that's true Nam Nexus Michelle says that
the nice thing about the NX is this
surface for loading she doesn't need to
heave her bag into the vehicle if you
need even more capacity you can open up
a second storage space it can hold even
bigger bags none once thought I'll go SL
etosha non-settling the interior
features quality materials craftsmanship
and luxury are on display everywhere
[Music]
one highlight is the two-tone leather in
the front and back and the interior
doesn't just look good it's also
comfortable
[Music]
the Lexus and x-wing Michelle says that
the Lexus NX is a feel-good car with a
space it's expertly used materials and
comfort it's almost like a sofa on
wheels
the Lexus NX 300h uses both a
four-cylinder and a hybrid engine the
motor has 145 kilowatts of power and a
top speed of 180 kilometers an hour it
goes from 0 to 100 and 9.2 seconds in
hybrid mode the car consumes 5 litres of
fuel per 100 kilometers supposedly our
tests yielded different results
[Applause]
I'll tell jibun Michelle says the
wind-driven on the Autobahn at an
average speed of 130 the car uses nine
liters here on this country road the car
is using 7.5 liters per 100 kilometers
alexis NX 300h is a stately car for
everyday use or longer trips
design : Nexus Michelle says that the
handling of the NX 300h isn't really
what you'd call sporty but you wouldn't
expect that from a car this size but she
was surprised at how agile such a large
car could be when she got it ruling the
hybrid engine of the NX 300h can be
driven in a variety of modes drivers
choose between eco normal and sport and
the normal mode the car ensures the
optimal distribution of power while the
Eco mode avoids using gasoline
[Music]
[Applause]
Michelle says that this Japanese car is
certainly competitive with its hybrid
engine it follows the spirit of the
times and she likes the extravagant
exterior does me a peasant's egg would
go felt